wer weiß schon freuen
jeder tag ist
er weiß schon heute wo wir morgen sind
wir morgen wieder alles neu begeht
schätze herrn bilanz weiter
so wir sind heute im wertstoffhof in
münchen und meine frage ist warum ist
müll denn eigentlich wertvoll da ganz
normaler abfall die essensreste die
sollen zu hause in der mülltonne bleiben
was wir jetzt hier haben alle wertstoffe
die man noch irgendwie verwerten kann
sowas wie holz eisen wieder dinge draus
machen kann
recyceln kann alles was zu uns kommt ist
sozusagen schon mal positiv und es kann
ruhig viel sein
glock drücken
wir haben wir von unseren proberaum los
in uralten fernseher dabei sie können
sicherlich sagen wo wir unterbringen
können ja logisch elektrogeräte
allgemein beinhalten sehr viele
wertstoffe unter einem namen metalle die
kann man hier vornehmen und seinem
speziellen fernsehmonitore container ab
wir brauchen es einfach nur da
reinstellen und gut ist es gibt also
auch problemmüll
es müssen schwierig denn so entsorgen
es war in letzter zeit immer so eine
debatte mit den energiesparlampen
energiesparlampen sollen ja energie
sparen aber umweltfreundlich sind sie
ganz und gar nicht in diesen
energiesparlampen ist jede menge
quecksilber das reinste gift das heißt
auf keinen fall in die mülltonne
schmeißen unbedingt zu uns kommen also
immer brav müll sortieren zum
wertstoffhof bringen könnten
diese boxen separat sortiert in sagen
wir mal elektroteile klein wenigen
bücher dann ja dann wird ein warmes
bitterkeit
es ist so bitter kalt doch ich werde
nicht als tja ich bin in diesen alten
müll so verklagte die sammel das ganze
zeug nicht und ich bring es hierher und
ihr seht es hier ist noch viel mehr haut
in die klampfe und ich mag es nicht wenn
ich hier einen freestyle kick einfach
finde ich für die kamera also ja ich bin
nicht mehr lange dann tschüss auf
wiedersehen ich hoffe dass wir uns bald
wiedersehen